President Trump is backing a Republican
plan to cut legal immigration in half he
faces strong opposition over what would
be the most significant change to our
immigration system in more than half a
century the bill sponsored by Senate
Republicans Tom cotton and David Perdue
is tilted towards highly-skilled
immigrants but it would make it harder
for immigrants in the u.s. to bring
their families along the president spoke
yesterday as a new poll showed 61% of
Americans disapprove of his job
performance 33 percent approve major
Garrett is at the White House with the
bill that many critics are denouncing
major good morning good morning Canada
Trump promised over and over to fix
immigration president Trump toyed with
the idea of pushing comprehensive
immigration reform but for now is
focusing on just one part of the system
the part that appears least broken and
has the most bipartisan support this
legislation demonstrates our compassion
for struggling American families who
deserve an immigration system that puts
their needs first and that puts America
first President Trump called for deep
cuts in legal immigration endorsing a
bill that prioritizes green cards for
wealthier applicants who speak English
and have sought after job skills the
bill would also limit so-called a chain
migration where family members gain
entry to the US through lawful green
card holders and it has not been fair to
our people to our citizens to our
workers the proposal would reduce legal
immigration from 1 million annually now
to about 500,000 annually within a
decade the administration argues the
current system drives down wages for
working-class Americans but critics say
favoring highly-skilled immigrants
creates a shortage of low-wage workers
you just can't find an American born
laborer to do those jobs South Carolina
Republican Lindsey Graham said the bill
would harm his state's
two top industries agriculture and
tourism if you're running a restaurant
orgoth Wars you realize how hard it is
to find David Boren labor others argue
the bill would encourage illegal
immigration
Kevin Appleby is with the Center for
migration studies it's gonna create a
magnet for people to come and fill those
jobs and and undocumented people are
gonna try to cross the border or
overstay their visas and fill those
positions White House senior policy
adviser Stephen Miller said the focus
should be on the American worker the
reason why some companies want to bring
in more unskilled labor it's because
they know that it drives down wages and
reduces labor costs our question as the
government is to whom is our duty our
duty is to u.s. citizens and US workers
to promote rising wages for them the
proposal is a legislative longshot to be
sure and not an immediate priority of
the republican-controlled Congress far
more important tax reform raising the
debt ceiling and passing a federal
budget flat major thanks